préparation des budgets c'est très
difficile surtout dans la période que
nous sommes en train de vivre
alors il ya plusieurs contraintes comme
on dit c'est à dire plusieurs
obligations à respecter ou plusieurs
réalités dont il faut qu'on tienne
compte
la première de ces réalité c'est que les
dotations de l'état c'est l'argent qui
vient de l'état est en très forte baisse
il suffit d'ouvrir son journal d'écouter
la radio le matin pour savoir que les
difficultés budgétaires du pays sont
telles que désormais l'argent qu'ils
venaient de l'état aux collectivités
locales qui étaient très souvent une
compensation
cet argent là va être en très très forte
baisse évidemment ça retenti sur le
budget des collectivités locales
le deuxième la deuxième réalité dont il
faut qu'on tienne compte et dont je veux
qu'on tienne compte c'est que pau est
une ville où les impôts sont très haut
depuis des années des années pour
plafonnent
les impôts la taxe d'habitation la taxe
foncière impose son la taxe d'habitation
spécialement sont très très haut et tout
le monde le sait selon moi c'est une des
raisons qui explique que dans les
années précédentes dans des six ou huit
années précédentes
pau et perdu des habitants ça c'est la
deuxième chose
la troisième chose c'est qu'il faut à
tout prix qu'on réalise un certain
nombre d'équipements qui pour l'instant
n'existe pas et dont on a le plus grand
besoin alors vous voyez ces trois
éléments là qu'il faut qu'on dont il
faut qu'on tienne compte dont il faut
qu'on prenne compte
ils nous ont guidés dans la préparation
de ce budget qui est à mon sens un
effort tout à fait remarquable pour
avoir une bonne gestion
alors premier effort nous allons
maintenir l'investissement deuxième
effort nous allons baisser des impôts
dont troisième effort nous allons tenir
les dépenses
nous allons maintenir l'investissement
la ville de pau va investir
les prochaines 25 millions d'euros
l'agglomération 15 millions et ça c'est
pas de l'argent qui part en fumée c'est
des réalisations qui vont se faire lors
ces réalisations vous les avez présente
à l'esprit mais je les rappelle on va
avoir de nouvelles halles des halles
était vraiment au coeur de la ville
quelque chose qui était pas acceptable
dans son état deuxièmement nous allons
vers un nouveau stade plus exactement un
embellissement et un agrandissement du
stade
troisièmement nous allons vers la
réalisation à la place de de l'abandon
de bâtiments qui est au centre ville
dans le cadre il à terre
musées bibliothèques et puis la place
qui est condamné aujourd'hui est à
l'abandon centre ville nous allons
travailler à installer l'école
supérieure des arts à la place de
l'ancienne bibliothèque et à faire une
place des arts au centre ville de pau
avec j'espère un jardin comme le jardin
du musée rodin à paris avec des
sculptures et tout ça c'est évidemment
une réhabilitation du centre ville et
puis on va s'occuper des rues et puis on
va s'occuper de l'éclairage et de ce
point de vue là on va considérablement
améliorer l'équipement et le rayonnement
de la ville
deuxièmement nous allons baisser les
impôts l'an dernier en fin 2014 la
première année de notre arrivée nous
avons baissé les impôts de 1 %
nous allons continuer à les baisser
alors sur un rythme moindre en raison de
la baisse des dotations mais on va
continuer à les baisser de 0 2% et nous
allons en tout cas c'est notre volonté
maintenir tout au long du temps
cette baisse progressive de manière que
au moins tout le monde se rende compte
que
notre volonté est d'alléger autant que
possible et c'est difficile pour une
ville centre des impôts parce que comme
vous le savez les villes-centres
assument des responsabilités que les
villes périphériques n'assume pas ça
c'est la deuxième orientation et puis la
troisième orientation nous allons tenir
les dépenses tout en améliorant
l'efficacité des services publics prévus
dès la première année ce que nous avons
fait par exemple du point de vue de la
propreté c'est très très important
puisque nous avons effacé tout l'état du
centre ville nous avons eu une démarche
très très volontaire pour que les places
et les rues de la ville notamment au
centre qui appartient à tous où tout le
monde vient soit propre et
nous avons même réussi à enlever une
grande quantité d des chewing gum qui
était sur le sol vous savez ces taches
noires genre pétrole d'ailleurs c'est au
fond la composante principale des
chewing gum qui sont collés sur le sol
et bien nous avons sur les rues pavées
nettoyer des choses donc la propreté
c'est très important
la sécurité c'est très important nous
allons dans l'année qui vient mettre en
place une brigade de nuit
nous avons mis des caméras de
vidéosurveillance dans la ville alors
qu'il n'y en avait pas et on va
continuer cet effort et nous avons
amélioré les horaires des médiathèques
par exemple tous à cet effort conduit
par la ville et l'agglomération
c'est un effort pour ce long d'une
une vision que je crois très importante
il faut faire avec moins d'argent mais
il faut faire mieux avec moins
on peut améliorer les services publics
on peut faire en sorte que les gens s'y
retrouvent
on peut avoir une simplification de
l'administration des fonctionnaires
beaucoup plus présents des agents de la
ville beaucoup plus présent songez que
avant que nous arrivions en six ans
l'absentéisme était passée de 9% des
agents à 16 % des agents 1%
d'absentéisme
en plus tous les ans et c'est incroyable
et c'est aussi la preuve d'un malaise
c'est profond qui existe est évidemment
dans les services alors notre travail
c'est d'entendre d'écouté par exemple je
reçois les agents de la ville un samedi
par mois sans rendez vous autant qu'ils
le veulent je trouve que c'est à la fois
une marque d'attention et en même temps
un moyen de re motiver l'ensemble de
ceux qui travaillent au service de la
ville voilà de quelle manière
en tenant les impôts en baissant les
impôts en maintenant l'investissement
pour des réalisations nouvelles pour le
rayonnement de la ville et en améliorant
des services publics en des tout en
dépensant moins
voilà de quelle manière nous avons bâti
le budget de la cité c'est à dire de la
ville de pau et de l'agglomération
pour l'année qui vient et cet effort-là
nous maintiendrons au travers du temps
voilà les idées qui ont présidé à la
mise en place à l'élaboration du budget
que vous allez trouver si vous vous
intéressez aux chiffres en allant sur ce
site